all right everybody welcome to another
YouTube session live hangout really
excited to be here with paul rodgers and
we're going to talk about how to
redefine your fear which I'm excited to
talk about a little bit of history and
how we met paul wrote in to me a
heartwarming email about how is a
teacher in a northern quebec community
dealing with the aboriginals and in as
part of their morning routine they watch
one of the top 10 videos to kind of
inspire and motivate them because in the
Aboriginal community it's a hard to stay
motivated so uh I was touched by that
and actually you know what well let's
say hey welcome Paul welcome aboard well
hey hi I was thinking just has no sane
that I was thinking I know that we've
ever profile an Aboriginal person on the
channel yet whether an entrepreneur or
athlete or or you know politician or
anybody I so I love it you don't have
anybody comes to mind but I like that
I'd like to connect with you after that
to see if you guys are watching this
every day at your school I'd love to
give them somebody even if it's you know
it was nothing come back but Aboriginal
American or somebody who did well just
as a little motivation let's connect
after to figure that out here that
schedule a day it'd be cool i like it i
love it when teachers are using this
kind of stuff in there in the schools it
gets me going because the earlier we can
hit the kids the better it really it
really worked because it was one thing
me trying to actually it was a two adult
education it was trying to get people
how to start a business to get them
motivated and get them fired up thinking
well being what an entrepreneur is
because a lot of them actually thought
will the entrepreneur is the easy route
and i was like no no guys this is the
eventually of the two paths you could
take taking a paycheck each month is the
easy one now you've actually decided to
step off the path and actually do it
yourself and a great idea but it's very
hard to keep the candle burning and
that's where the daily i try to get them
into a habit we're actually they come in
watch that in the morning and then we
discuss it for a while and they will
pick their own star
rather than me just tell them they pick
so and it they always pick the guys who
who was the underdog which was really
good and they are the most inspiring
people and they were pumped afterwards I
mean and they were really open to
learning and you know it and got them to
write down their favorite quote so near
the end of course they are able to go
around and and actually quote the rock
quote President Obama and it was a
really really good thing okay so let's
do this here's what i heard here's the
trade you don't want to make a trade
here and the good okay i'm gonna make a
video of an aboriginal well we'll
discuss on who it is and because i want
i want the kids to make a video seeing
their favorite quote that they put
together and doesn't be crazy like to
get a phone and whatever every kid has
their own like the thing that they
learned the most favorite cool good deal
of economics i love it good i want to
see it good um cool okay so then like
paul and i are catching up here uh
background Paul wanted to do a survey on
fear and has this here buddy up for
people to learn about fear and how to
overcome it I wanted to interview people
who are you know their thoughts on fear
and so I said hey Paul love to help
let's do it as a YouTube hang out so
everybody can learn to and not just me
right now dancer so I don't even looked
at the questions cuz I like it would be
so like but live real response real time
here okay ready [ __ ] about fear let's go
I hope the the questions from the survey
so watch watch evens face to see if they
hit and hit the mark or not so we're
okay first question what is the biggest
fear you have experienced ok start ah
the clock appears on that in the top
left-hand corners yeah I need any de
jeopardy music um I i would say on a
like a fear like a physical fear like a
you know whole body reaction is probably
probably or something around heights
roller coasters like one on roller
coaster and like fighting it um that's
just more like on a body you know that's
that's a phobia and it has a physical
effect on your body right which really
they will mimic that feeling that's the
feeling you're gonna get yeah I think I
think I also feel like that fear like
necessarily holds me back uh you know so
I can't ride roller coasters you know
will be um but I think more the the more
crippling fear that I had that was less
physical but more mental was letting
people down fear of letting people down
fear of not provide enough value and i
would i would secretly hope that people
would cancel meetings with me because i
was afraid that I wouldn't be able to
provide value to them either on a
one-on-one meeting a coffee meeting or E
or like big presentations like hey I get
hired to go speak at this event in Asia
and I would secretly hope that it would
cancel on me you know the week before
saying oh sorry I'm gonna topic I no
worries it's cool okay right it's why
we're it's also tied into what I love
like I love that and and it's the fear
of getting into it but once i'm there i
love it i love the interaction after it
my you know my purpose is helping people
especially entrepreneurs and so it's
interesting that that need to
over-deliver in and give people value
it's probably why i do so much and why I
put so much work in time and effort into
it but that hurt me earlier on in my
career of just feeling like I wouldn't
give enough value in and maybe not doing
as many meetings as I should or secretly
hoping the people with canceled on me so
maybe not as big and a reaction is like
oh my god I'm going on a roller coaster
by unison dumpling is their own spare
and they will you know it that's that
that's the thing it's a very unique to
the individual every single person there
might be the fear of public speaking is
it that they're of you know it is it
will feel like a focus symptoms will
come out sweaty palms worried anxious
you know keeping up at night there are
the symptoms of the problem so will will
go into the second one because it links
to it says what did you do to manage the
fear so now you've identified what did
you do to manage their I so for the
roller coaster one I just don't do it
you know avoidance avoidance is the
managing you know don't go on roller
coasters don't jump off bridges don't
put myself in situations where I have to
face it that's probably I think that's
more that's kind of standard default
thing that will do uh and then
recognizing does that behavior hold you
back does that does that the other you
from getting to where you want to go and
so again hope you back in a major part
of your life you can live with actually
just thinking and again it's redefining
it is actually ok that is something
which I do not have to face on a
day-to-day basis so it's not important I
can actually avoid it if it's something
which comes up say for example public
speaking so you got to Asia and actually
you've suddenly discovered actually I
get written you hear the musicians
getting this stage fright when they have
to go on stage and perform and it's that
sort of look this is my job I've got to
actually go so how do you how do you
manage your fear of the over delivery
when you are it's starting out yeah so I
think the starting point is just
awareness that is happening I think we
just go through life following what's
been conditioned upon us and what we
felt in and we just fall back on these
habits and routines that don't often
support us so I didn't even I wasn't
even aware that this was a problem and I
think for a lot of us you're doing
things you not even aware our problem
just you just do it naturally and so I
remember there was this one woman in
particular I was gonna go meet her for
coffee she just started by entrepreneur
you know this is maybe I don't know four
years ago three years ago startup
entrepreneur who you don't want to me
for coffee great i'm gonna go out and
just before like half a number 4 i'm
like ahh i'm checking my email that you
cancel that you can't tell hope she
cancelled you know like I don't want to
go out I you know I'm nervous and I'm
thinking men you know this is this is
silly and then when I met with her and
it was great and she left inspired and I
felt great
I was able to help somebody further
along their path and I remember just
walking back to my place after thinking
this so it's so bad it's so detrimental
to what I want to do and that this is
something that I really love and there's
no need to be scared I've done this so
many times I help people so many times
why am I so afraid and once I asked the
question once I had the awareness then
it just started just started changing I
just stopped caring as much the next
time that it happened that I got nervous
I remind myself oh it's just like that
woman yeah and it's me know great like I
don't need to be nervous or afraid um
remoting in the mind are amazing that
that once you actually a lot of people
spend a lot of time actually trying to
work out what that what it is and then
once you actually got to that solution
path that's where you can actually put
things in where people will say okay do
that by having a routine I've created
you your trigger point was to actually
you think back to that one where you
actually realized it and that's an sort
of sets a new behave and conditions you
to actually change which is which is
which is great yeah and building more
confidence through practice and and
trusting myself more if i look back to
this if we did this five years ago i
would have wanted to know every question
i wouldn't want it to work it out you
know exactly what i was going to answer
have it all perfectly set out because it
be worried about all like Paul's coming
on I gotta give them value I make sure
that there's you know I'm helping him
out and you know but then I realized
that in a lot of the answers i was given
they felt rehearsed they felt prepared
it wasn't really genuine wasn't in the
heart and and it's i realized as much
more about how you say something than
the exact words that you're saying
Absalom and the intent behind it so i
was saying great things but the message
we're missing the market no back my
youtube channel watch what i was doing
five six years ago the content is pretty
much the same but my delivery and the
emotion behind it is just way better now
because i'm not just trying to memorize
words and so I forced myself to get into
that kind of situation where
I don't want to see the questions right
like my assistant like you know I don't
want to know though i don't know let's
just go do alive we'll see what happens
the problem is you see because if you
actually almost the enemy is you
actually start getting to overthink when
you overthink it sounds like it's it's
you know it's rehearsed and everything
else and and that doesn't they takes
away the genuineness from it because
people actually and everyone watching
this will actually think yeah actually
we can see by reactions it's the first
time you heard the questions and that's
the that's the that's the genuine
response yeah I still think the hardest
part of all of it is just having the
self-awareness to know what what the
fear is I think once you've identified
this thing that's holding you back you
know as human beings we're problem
solvers especially entrepreneurs your
problem solvers and give us a problem
ago we'll go and find it we don't tackle
some but we don't know the problem is
and we don't know what to do so you know
I spent I spent I don't know I spent 20
20 how old am I know I spent like 30
plus years of my life doing that
probably just the awareness of it
allowed me to in a not like overnight
but in a matter of months lose it well i
started my career as a as a trained
lawyer so I commercial lawyer for 10
years it doesn't look like that now with
a haircut for trust me I did have a
corporate here one stage and and that's
you know I gave business advice but
actually I found that very small
percentage the advisors giving was law
it was actually solving problems for
other people and being outside the
problem means you can actually see the
wood for the trees and then I moved into
the kite surfing which a game was
actually tackling fear right at the base
because people are terrified when they
get on the beach and it's blowing a gale
and they feel the Chi pulling them and
you see the characters leave power all
those five years of running via running
going on the roller coaster there the
fears which you actually try to tame and
that that's quite an interesting way so
it's all led to this this point let's
let's go on to the next one this is
quite interesting this was the balance
of the vice positive or negative if you
talk to other people about the fair you
talk to other people about
20 you at i'm gonna sell this myself
sort of uh i think that depends on your
personality yeah I'm introverted so I
like the problem solved myself I think
it's like how do you do with any problem
not just what's your natural way of
solving problems how did you like to
study when you're in school do you like
to study in a group would you like to
study by your by yourself you know I'm
I'm introverted it may not they may not
seem that way but you know I need to
spend a lot of time with myself ah I
can't be out and like meeting after
meeting social settings I hate
networking events so I'd like to have at
least a framework for solving a problem
worked out before I would talk to
anybody about it and when I'm in
problem-solving mode actually other
people's energy doesn't vibe with me you
know like if my wife asked me what's
wrong and I'm in the middle of it like I
need to deal with this yeah I don't want
to share I don't want to talk about it
we'll talk about it afterwards when I
have kind of figured things out and I
need help on the next plane but that's
me I just think however you solve your
problems normally if you get energy from
other people then then share it with
them and if you need to do it yourself
then then topic you know your wife
person recognizes that actually because
you've been with you for a while now
your behavior that actually when she
does talk to you at that point is the
time oh he's in the middle of a solving
a problem so it's that sort of
companionship not easy to start with I'm
sure yeah and also me like explaining
like listen I'm you know it can be okay
yeah like it can be it can come off as
offensive it can come off as a mean like
oh he doesn't want to share what he's
going through with me I'm his partner
you know I'm his wife on you know but it
just comes off of me having explained
this is my personality I'm introverted I
need to figure out things for myself at
least a framework and then I can when I
made sense of that then I can go out and
and so then I had to make sure that
she's the first person that I just look
you go getta make sure she gets the sign
version of that book yes yes you've been
watching you guys see I said well I
think that she's going to figure out
even this you know I said this before
but like the office how is set up yep I
have my picture of us and and Hayden
that's usually here because I look at it
because my computer is here but then
she's upset that she's not in this so I
gotta move it on Thursdays that she's in
the shot here um but what doesn't mean
it's just fun it's all fine but that was
a serious thing where like you know I
need the times myself to do it and and
then I changed to be the first one that
I tell when right yeah I'm when I the
results came in from from the people i
had actually talked to and and another
one reason why a lot of people actually
felt they had to do it themselves is
because they're in a such a sense the
position of employment that they
actually have to keep things very
confidential they can't go and tell
everyone so they were forced to actually
pradhan soul themselves and then go and
speak to people afterwards so that was
another that sort of same sort of
behavior came out for that type of that
type of job as well so it's if there are
different ways of solving it other than
just talking to everyone and and so it's
interesting one thing I would say I feel
like a lot of people might do it
themselves because they're they're
afraid of sharing their fear still a day
right but if that's not how you problem
solve like maybe I'm fortunate that I
don't want I don't need to share it it's
actually counterproductive for me to
share too early but if you're the kind
of person who needs to share and needs
feedback and and you just ball it all up
I then have the courage to share what's
going on with the people in your lives
because when you are open vulnerable I
know it's scary but people people will
rush to support you absolutely rush to
help and share so don't be afraid like
if that's how you solve problems don't
don't keep a bottle up and golden
whether it's your parents or friends or
even an Internet community brandy
anonymous whatever like get it up and
get some feedback it was interesting
when when when they sin the survey which
the results are actually in the sort of
paid for video that actually it was
different the different sectors people
went to vary
large bit obviously went to friends and
family close but it then was a question
of the advice was was was actually when
it came it was not always welcome advice
because it's actually most of the time
it was a projection of what their the
person was fearing themselves so as a
positive advice for the negative taint
on it was like well yes you can do it
but and it was you know that was the
difficult thing of sharing it you
actually have to sort through stuff
people are liking your good lights by
the way in the car so that's kind his
dreadlocks are fire and so it's hot so
they're there they're feeling it just
sort of let you know for the people
watching this is I can't thank first
Youtube hang out so I think you're
rocking it man you did a great job thank
you thank you well let's test let's not
let you off the hook here because you
might be having an easy ride so let's
sir let's crack on with these questions
all right was it such a big deal was
your fear justified ah I think fear is
very rarely justified at least our
emotional reaction to it I think in
there is a plus in it and that it helps
me be prepared and helps me over the
liver and helps me add more value but
but it's not people on most part it's
negative i think more it says it carries
way more negative than positive yeah i
know that the result was never was never
what I thought it was going to be right
like I've always provided value they
always had a great time I always left
energized I've never had a bomb of a
meeting or bomb of a presentation so see
that's wait you see the results are the
same it's just the your interpretation
almost of it was actually where the fear
was coming from is am i doing the right
thing but the results are actually were
consistent so it's it's fear rare and
you know you fear was controlled but
it's actually something which was was
inside you yeah I mean I think I think
it's mostly negative I wouldn't say all
negative because I do feel like it
pushed me to do more and push with it
make sure that I was over the lagoon
where if I just showed
I feel like oh I don't really care I
wouldn't have been asked occurred um but
for the most part yeah I look you know
it was it was negative and that the
result was never what you know my worst
case scenario that it's going on in my
head you know I don't even know what a
word like I didn't visualize somebody
walking out on me you're throwing water
go too scared I'm going home there was
no clear illustration in my head of what
that negative situation look like it was
it's maybe I don't know why I don't know
when you actually start examining is
really quite weird Levi what what was it
actually that was that terrifying and
never had a bad experience so what was
it is it is weird it's weird so we keep
with the weirdness what she didn't have
to do again what would you change you
know I get this question a lot from
different perspectives and I don't know
that I would change anything and maybe
that's a cliche answer um because it's
made me who I am it's like that standard
answer but I'm I love where I'm at in
life with everything that I'm doing and
so changing is kind of like I feel what
that movie is where they go back in time
and step on a butterfly and then the
comeback wait what they butterfly effect
it is that it I think it's no it's like
it's like an old anyway I don't know
maybe to come back and like this
dinosaurs and all their friends are dead
or whatever so that's a very Wade
butterfly standing yeah yeah well like
one minor change in the past could
create a ripple effect yet or so um I
remember recently watching I am NOT you
guru with Tony Robbins we're trying to
do something on my channel with him so I
want to know what kind of what's going
on so he and one of the segments talks
about how his father was not a great
father to him but because of his
father's who he is today so if he had
the perfect father he wouldn't be Tony
Robbins you know absolutely so you know
I'm sure if you like you know Paul if
you bring me you teleport me back there
that moment i'm sure you know like if
I'm sitting there I will I will change
knowing what I know if you could bottle
and sell hindsight you'd be a very very
wealthy yes because it's you know it's
always there are a lot of people who
said look you know I would have done it
sooner which I had more courage to do it
or change things that was sort of a lot
of people that they were stuck somewhere
like when they worked out what they
defied what the problem was when they
actually put things in place and when
they did it there and it was not such a
big deal like oh I don't know why spend
all that time I'm wasting my time
worrying you know we are trying to live
with those few regrets as possible I'm
really so like I've made a few very few
but uh those those few now make me not
want to live without regret in the
future so you know I wouldn't want to
change it it's almost like you know like
in sport they say you need to be able to
taste what losing feels like to really
appreciate what winning feels like under
and it's that sort of negative is see
that's the one that thing not all fear
is bad so that redefining it is
sometimes you think fear is all bad but
actually it's it's a it's like a good
bad it's actually helps shape that side
of you okay right what is different from
your new self from your old self so cast
your mind back to where you were pre pre
sort of oh my god this is not going to
turn out very well I think I'm in a
constant state of evolution yeah look at
that I love it like it is always my new
scarf right like just changes not as big
I guess from three years ago till from
yesterday kind of thing one day at a
time but I'm always like why I have my
top 10 rules videos because i wanna i
want to learn from them and i watch
those daily I want to grow I want to I
want these guys to rub off on me a
little bit more every day so it shows I
mean again it's you're absolutely right
you know the day
are not static and actually you pick up
stuff away through today so I'm hoping
that when when we look watch those
videos with the aboriginal class that
actually they have now got stuff which
is actually equip them for life and they
if they come up against the problem
they've got a richer fall back on stuff
to to actually the quotes and the
inspiring stuff is really helpful and
that helps deal with challenges one
percent I mean if I'm looking at how
I've evolved I might rather use that
word than noosaville so but whatever if
I like how I've changed in the past for
the past three years I think at the core
my values are still the same and you
know that's why my parents are up on the
wall I'm that little boy there like
seven years old in the middle um what
has changes more uh my confidence in
what I and what I'm doing in to be
myself and did not be not be ruled so
much by what other people might think
like I used to wear suit when i rose me
if I if we had this meeting five years
ago be in a suit I always just wear suit
and it slowly evolved and now I'm always
is what I wear like do you look at it
you know you're like that I didn't shave
today sorry pong and shave today you
know at least my left man yeah I would i
go to you know I sit down with last 12
weeks I was in Chicago with the CEO
sages runs a multi-billion dollar
company at 13,000 employees and this is
what i wore what i did it i go to black
tie events and our this with black pants
like you know i don't mind i don't care
like I don't you know people don't agree
with it then I you know I probably not
want to deal with those people anyway
we're not going to vibe well together i
mean what you know people do business
with people they like if they like you
they'll do the business with you it
doesn't matter what we know what flashy
stuff you do or how slick you come
across is actually you know do you like
or underneath and if you stick to hear
you are yeah for sure and one of your
changes which is obvious is the the new
slogan which of course and you know
believe and that whole direction which
should watch the video on and you know
of how you found that actually
condensing it all down to one word I
mean that's that's a evolution really
there as well yeah again that's one of
the things that I felt has always been
inside me it came from my parents that's
why they're up on here uh you know AP
Giannini there was the believe banker
who bet on Walt Disney when everybody
thought he was nuts and um this this
whole wall relates to believe somehow I
think just just like overcoming fear the
self awareness of what it was that I
stood for help because it was always
there but now understanding it allows me
to design a life and a business more on
purpose around it where once I started
focusing my business around believe
that's when everything took off so my
youtube channel to go off the newsletter
to God everything started doing that
much better just because I got the focus
on I mean that's parts in the book I
don't know that I involved that much
door I feel like that was always in me
it's just it's just that actually my
execution was different well if I look
at something like confidence I become
more confident in what I'm doing uh I
have less patience for mediocrity them
than I used to I have I have more drive
to get things done in a bigger way and
faster than I used to i'm gonna guess
some of the other you know believe in
execution maybe maybe maybe it's more
visible for people watching i guess but
if you look back on my channel again go
back six years and look at how I deliver
content it's yeah the camera never lies
that's the problem is it's a huge
evolution we can just skip back in
second six years or so so I mean one of
the things when I when I quit being a
lawyer which I got to a point where I
was pretty good at it I've been doing it
long enough and I then quit being a
lawyer to become a kite surf instructor
and it was a it was a complete excuse
the pun sea change of a life and the
matter people said oh you're never going
to make it you're never going to do it
and everything
a must I stubbornness is a very good
trait and in believing actually this is
what I wanted to do and ok you know I
didn't do it to become rich that wasn't
the idea I did it actually because I
wanted to do it and I enjoyed it and
actually it made it made a business out
of it which was cool the show the people
in the commons our scene instead of
evolution I should be saying evolution
when you had some car Adam Adam lacks we
got some comedians here and there you
need a higher them as your marketing
Gulen here look yeah okay I almost hi
look at look at something going Adam and
then we've got the last one here which
is so how do you feel after a sort of
having to del back into that sort of
that memory in those questions had how
do you feel now about the questions and
your what you've had to talk about
that's an interesting one ah I don't
often get asked that actually it's
interesting of all I'll give you a lot
of interviews but I haven't you don't
usually ask how do you feel after the
interview it's actually live live
reaction here live reaction folks watch
there ain't no um my immediate thoughts
and be honest is I like that as a as a
model I like that as just a you know
it's easy say okay well deal to the fear
I feel more you know I feel inspired to
feel more courageous I feel like oh I
overcame how much I've grown in the past
sex number years and it's all true what
what I really am excited by though is if
if use it like using that as a teaching
tool to people are going through it and
then asking them at the end how they
feel this is a self-reflection to like
sink in the the knowledge a little bit
more this is with time where I know your
feet to the floor so you cannot run away
this is that that's that question I like
it I like it it's good yeah so I mean
for me ie what I want to say you know it
I talk about a lot of this stuff and
we've talked about fear allah but i'd
share a lot of these two
was a lot it's always helpful to to come
back to them it's always helpful to like
look at the journey and see how far it's
come I'm fortunate that I get to do that
a lot with my youtube channel answering
questions in the comments coming up but
i really like honestly the that was like
the like instant reaction and then the
bigger one college teaching to all the
user at the end yeah the knee-jerk
reaction and then whilst your brain
starts running to try and find the right
file to look into yeah interesting cool
well I mean to us the what what actually
as you said that the last question is
there is actually you know sometimes
it's actually worth celebrating what
you've done because right actually they
don't actually realize that you know it
you know people's fears whether they're
their own fears they may sound silly to
other people but the feeling of that
individual and the person is real and
taking time just to celebrate that
you've done it you know it may be let's
take the roller coaster because it's
nice and extreme let's just say yeah you
went and rode your first roller coaster
and it wasn't so bad actually that's
cool I mean that's that doesn't mean
anything to a seasoned pro but to you as
an individual it's going to make you
feel good a seasoned pro roller coaster
I they're going to be out there I love
it we've got it if we've got people
chasing and match and Pokemon lunch I'm
looking forward to seeing who the first
pro roller coaster riding that's
interesting like this market there
there's something I'm sure I'm sure one
of your when you're up subscribe to
write in and say how many roller
coasters that they'll be the thing how
many rides have you done and the
challenge maybe that they might have to
drag you on one of them oh I'm setting
you up now that's terrible come on car
come on come on I'm gonna send Adam and
you by Adam discovery for me so fearless
I mean is very personal on that m and
another interesting question which I've
been sort of trying with in my head ISM
what comes first is it motivation or
fear or is it the chicken and egg which
which one come
first you think what comes first
motivation or fear um my instinct is to
say inspiration like you get inspired by
something and I think maybe just from my
own case I get inspired by something I
feel like motivation maybe something
afterwards but I get inspired by
something and then I might be afraid of
it that's what usually happens that
motivation starts fear them bolt itself
onto it onto the side of it and then
that then sometimes act is another
slingshot that throw you through yeah I
mean I thinking go both ways right now I
try to you know as an example I told the
storm the channel not that long ago I
moved in and they had these extra socks
and kind of those socks he keeps the
bottom of the pile you like secretly
hoping to find the matching pair of sock
with the matching sock is somewhere gone
and you know you never find it you just
have these single socks something about
to throw away the single socks moving to
the new condo and then my son Hayden I
just thought of him and how he always
wears different socks he net like he
will tear apart the matches to wear
mismatched socks with you know that's
his intention oh that's such you know
it's pretty cool and I thought maybe I
should do that uh and then the fear was
whoa how would people judge me I'm not
conforming anymore own right like what
if I never thought oh [ __ ] if I'm afraid
of it I gotta go do it so I went out and
with with intent one out to do that and
I went to a my salsa school and I taught
and then I lifted up my the bottom of my
pants and I showed them the socks and I
said hey you guys you know tilt in the
store and do something that you are
afraid of today this is kind of like a
life lesson so you know I guess I got
the inspiration from my son but I
wouldn't really go out and do it I did
it because of the like the fear became
the inspiration yeah no one to jump into
it to just get into practice of doing
things that are uncomfortable like even
this this is your first time doing a
google hangout a lot of a lot of people
say no a lot of people are afraid that
whatever how
load could they're set up whatever I
like all the reasons it's live people
are watching in micron you know they
were done it before and so it's
courageous to to come on and agree to do
this so well clap clap it up for pie
cool so is that the list that's here
unfortunately but you've managed to
survive and nearly nearly got you in my
last question that was sort of lull you
into a false sense security but ya know
that that's that's pretty much the the
question list but it you know it's
coming looked at the people's responses
to this you know it's it's it really is
quite amazing and that's why I've then
compiled the results in a series of
videos so actually so people there are
lots of different people that are from
people who have actually I've sort of
pick people who are going through their
people who I know have actually achieved
something like that set up their own
business they've done something which is
like you know in my in their view of my
view big and there's something in there
for everyone there's the introvert
there's this there's that so it's a name
really just to let people watch it and
pick out the bit which they think yeah
okay that sounds that sounds like me and
if there's something in there that's
perfect cool well there's a bunch of
people writing in Mabel just end on this
one pal wallahs as a pow wow how well
and probably go over there you're an
Indian Territory of you're saying pow
wows wow yeah wow well how well budka um
is asking what is this guy's name so so
Paul Rogers for Rogers and I mean if you
just want to give like just to end it
off ya know the only where people can
find you may feel like agilent the site
is called redefine your Fiat calm as a
Facebook page as well and a YouTube
channel when if you type in redefine
your fear or Paul Rogers redefine your
fear you'll find them there is there's
about 20 videos there at the moment on
different topics so see if there's
anything which actually gels as even
says you don't have to watch every video
that's not you know there's no extra
points for this but if there's something
there which
makes you smile changes something for
you then that's that's all good and the
idea really is you know if everyone has
a fair everyone has problems and it's
just trying to actually everyone is
their own warrior everyone is an expert
at solving problems and it's just
sometimes coming that just that bit of
friendly chat just to say yeah actually
that sounds like me I can do that and
it's an encouragement really I love it
welp I'll thank you for the time I
appreciate the opportunity interviewed
by guys watching hope you enjoy hope you
got inspired go check out the project
Paul make sure we connect about the
whole video thing after what I love that
deal that's gonna be cool okay cool
thank you guys have a great Friday into
the weekend continue to believe I will
see you soon excellent